all right natasha
hi natasha where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i grew up around
here in california
in uh in san marino in a really nice
part
it's a wealthy suburb of l.a yes yes
you're pasadena
and tell me how your childhood advice um
my childhood was good until i was about
five
when my uncle started molesting me till
i was about
13 and so that's
i think how i became like
okay with with being so sexual you know
like um
the only reason why he stopped is
because he had passed away
through a car accident and so
i mean i don't know how much longer it
would have went on but
shortly after that around 16
i started using drugs by 17 i was well
into like
you know using heroin the heroin
used to still to this day to this day
wow
and that's kind of what brought me down
here um
i had a dealer you know i went to a
really
you know good school catholic school um
after that i i you know i continued on
with my drug use
and and i got caught up with a guy
who who like dealt in big quantities of
heroin
so i constantly had like you know i'm
driving around with like
you know like 48 grams of heroin two
ounces on me like it's nothing in a
hollow kitty bag
um i don't know what happened he
he just fell off i don't know if he got
caught up or
but i didn't really know any of his
people it was just him that i knew and
i had nobody else and and you know
somebody told me about
skid row and so i rolled down here um
me and my homegirl and she and at that
time this was about four years ago
and she smoked crack and so that's when
i started to you know
like smoke crack and get a little like
more crazy
um i was having a hard time with you
know my my guy not being around
and stuff and and so we rolled down here
and
the first block we hit we scored
we left of course i came back the next
day
came back the day after that i
eventually met the guy who ran the block
and i got caught up with him and never
went back home
he ended up being a pretty big gangster
down here and
and you know it took me
you know till i was 40 to like get a
hand laid on me
i never experienced you know besides the
the molestation that my uncle did which
was you know of course normal
i thought was normal you know
i experienced now like getting beat by
this guy
and um
it was you know by that i i mean by that
time too i was prostituting
i was you know just trying to make ends
meet
um he he wasn't always
okay with it you know i was supposed to
stay on the block
and you know sell crack and and make
money but
you can't sell what you smoke you know
so
i smoke up my sack a lot faster than i
would sell it so it was a constant like
beating um i was
you know i knew how to count so i kept
track of his books i organized that that
was no problem but
but to make any kind of money back i
couldn't so i'd go
homing and crazy [ __ ] would happen
you know i get dropped off all over town
i'd get kicked out of cars i won't get
you know they wouldn't pay
this last time i mean i finally i
finally got away
some guy had me in his tent for
i felt like it was two weeks i think it
was only like four days
but he had me like tied up [ __ ]
just you know all crazy [ __ ]
like the only way i i got out
was his girlfriend came like i guess she
took off she was pissed she came
asked who the [ __ ] was in the tent and i
managed to [ __ ]
like get away in my [ __ ] like
underwear walking down the street
i got you know i i i haven't talked that
guy that i was with
on the block he ended up getting
arrested for two counts of murder and
one attempt
so i don't even have him right now you
know what i mean like
i met somebody who keeps who's got me
off the street still down here but
but i have a trick looking for me right
now that that i
that goes up and down wanting to like
you know want thinking he wants to help
but
but isn't you know he's just controlling
and stuff like that
but that that four days and that down
was really
crazy i think that was like the worst
experience i ever had like not knowing
if you're gonna get out or
what the [ __ ] is going on being like
being like you know like
your eyes wrapped up and your hands
taped like i'm
like i come from san marino you know
like
i don't i'm free to come and go as i
please you know i i didn't really have
any rules or anything you know my
parents were
always working and stuff so
i've learned real fast down here you
know like i've been down here now like i
said
four years and it's it's it's between
you know the tricks down here and the
guys that run the block
it's it's been you know an experience
i can't when you were a young girl did
you have dreams or plans for your life
you know and i think that's what kind of
like i've never been a person that had
any kind of like i want to be you know a
lawyer when i grow up
and i don't i don't know if that was my
uncle like touching me at such a young
age like i didn't know where
or what like i wanted to be you know
like
i knew it wasn't right but then it just
seemed
it was unsaid you know like it wasn't
like spoke
of you know until you know he died in
the car accident like what the hug like
my
parents you know like i said my parents
really weren't home like but
i i don't i don't know i mean i hate to
use a crutch you know
for like my drug use or where i am but
i mean it all builds up to where you are
in life you know
and are your parents still in your life
my mom passed away but my dad's still
around i don't really
i have a sister but she she doesn't
understand
you're kind of on your own now do you
have kids
i have a daughter i have a daughter
she's at 20. she
she she goes to college she stays with
her dad out in san bernardino
um yeah i really haven't seen her in the
last like eight years
and do your friends know
no friends from home that i talk to
um i do have like a friend that i'm
staying with right now
that got me like you know off the
streets but that's
that's enough anyone in your life that
you truly trust
i want to say so
i mean it's just it's you don't know you
don't know who's gonna like you know
people seem like they're cool and then
next you know you know
pinned on the floor with your pants down
you know
or you're you've been like hit so hard
your face hits the [ __ ] asphalt and
your eyes cracked open
like i don't everybody seems so nice at
first you know i come from like where i
come from of course you trust
everybody walk around no shoes on you
know but
you'll step on a [ __ ] syringe out
here
no it's a big adjustment from where you
grew up right it is did you find
yourself like every
every year or every six months you kind
of start
you find yourself adapting more and more
to oh how horrible it is here
oh yes oh yes i've learned to pee in any
sort of kind of cup
you know you're staying in a tent or
yeah you have stages i was in a tent
i wasn't a tent until like this last
time that a trick
you know got like kept me for four days
i don't even
and i have that other one driving up and
down looking for me
because you know he wants to be like
captain save a hoe and
take me off the streets and the person
who i'm staying with now is going to be
just
tor like it's just no better than you
know what i've been doing but
he hasn't you know he hasn't shown any
of that yet and of course
my trusting self is gonna you know
believe it have you ever been clean from
heroin
since i was 17 between like
yeah when i have my daughter between
like 20 to 22
and then i just seem to like start using
again you know either i become
you know i find myself you know alone
or pulling tricks and you can't pull a
trick without be
i don't know i can't without being
[ __ ] up yeah i think it'd be very hard
for
hard to do that kind of work without
being high or drunk or something yeah
yeah and down here it just seems like
every trick is like
angry and violent and and and just
hard and just not you know what i mean
like you got to be [ __ ] up to [ __ ]
numb yourself to that you know because
you know you're going to need that money
afterwards
for whatever is going to happen when you
get out of that car if you get out of
that car
it's such a horrible life right it has
been in terms of what
how you're living and what you're doing
to survive and i mean i know
it doesn't have to be because of where i
came from i know there's another way
but this way has been so much of my life
you know i don't know what would you
attribute that to
i mean i can bring up the molestation
that would be an obvious one but
that and like i think too like i think
my parents spoiled me
a lot because of that so i had no real
responsibility i knew
what it was to like work hard you know
um so they pampered you after oh yeah
yeah like my laziness and stuff and just
wanting to be high
just wanting to get high at the end of
the day and does shame play a part in
your life
oh every day every day
you know i think why i wear like a wig
every day you know i don't want anybody
to see what i
look like
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your
in your life
not to sit on another man's bed in their
tent
[Music]
just [ __ ] just really you need to really
rely on yourself
because when you start to rely on other
people that's when you become
in debt to them and that's when they
want your debt paid
in any shape way or form is it hard for
a woman
out here it must be right oh yes oh yeah
harder than
being a guy i think so i mean i i think
a lot so
i mean i think it's easier for them to
make money in some ways
but they're gonna pay for it they're
going to pay for it
you know
because i've been you know
violated in every which way like i i you
know
thinking i'm going to go and you know
just have sex with you and being raped
and butt [ __ ] you know and it's just
like whoa
you know but you have to take it because
you're already in and [ __ ] it
if he gives you that money afterwards
just [ __ ] suck it up
that's what it's about do you feel like
you're just a commodity out here
oh down here now yeah usually i think to
the guy who had the block
like i was you know i was he wanted just
you know a pretty face to sell the dope
you know guys wanted a smoke to come in
the tent
um just to [ __ ] you know
i can count to 10 without using my
fingers
and that you know and from you know
maybe one day i'll pay off because of
where i came from too
when i would take off and like try to go
hide from him that was his biggest thing
that [ __ ]
don't belong here that [ __ ] is from san
marino
that vision from here you know but that
that's also money in the bank for him if
anything you know
but i just i couldn't do it but this
last time i took off and when i
that trick got me in that tent and just
had me [ __ ]
duct tape like that was just [ __ ]
stupid
you know blindfolded and
i i i've never experienced anything
like where my power has been so taken
away for so long you know like of course
it's been small
like you know 10 15 minutes and then you
get pushed out of the car and like money
thrown on you you know
it's like an ongoing series of traumatic
events that just
keep coming right yes and the more
that happen the more drugs you do you
know and then the farther you go down
and the farther you don't see your way
out
you know i've been you know arrested
for stupid [ __ ] you know and these cops
down here are full of [ __ ] i've got
arrested last time for domestic violence
how are you going to arrest me for
domestic violence you know
but they can just pluck you right off
the street and put you in a cement box
no questions asked you know
so that's that's another scary thing you
know either you're taking it you're
putting a 10 or you're taking and you
put in a cell like it's
you don't know which one like when you
wake up and you step
outside do you have hope today of
turning your life around i don't i don't
i think eventually i'll
i'll be found dead
really i do i do
you come close to it so many times that
you could see that happen i do
i don't see any any hope you know i'll
get out of jail
i'll be in there nine days think i can
stay clean
you know it doesn't happen i gotta go
pull a trick because
i gotta eat and in order to do that i
gotta be high
i gotta be high because i don't know
what the [ __ ] gonna happen when i get
in that car
i don't know you know i've been left
over and [ __ ] like
thousand oaks i've been left over and
[ __ ]
just some crazy ass [ __ ] areas you
know
off by like the two um just
it's just i don't know i wish there was
hope
i wish i had hope i don't think so
anymore
i just think if you know i hate to hold
on to my uncle
and think like you know if he didn't
come into that room and he didn't
[ __ ]
touch me the way he did like maybe my
life would have been different you know
or
or if i didn't drive down that block
down here
and meet that guy i you know i wanted a
[ __ ]
i wouldn't have had those [ __ ] you
know
bruises you know those [ __ ] black
eyes or those
you know busted [ __ ] noses and
you know and that's the [ __ ] that just
keeps me holding on you know
and and i know i don't know it's going
to kill me
but it's almost like you're it seems
like you're addicted to being down here
because you're free to leave you could
you could walk away and go to another
life and go to a women's shelter and
maybe get
you can have like the fear of like
change too and the fear of not like
having like like not getting high
like okay maybe i can stop heroin and
just smoke crack
but the fact that you know what i mean
to be like completely clean
i don't know if i can do that and deal
with all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] in my head
all those [ __ ] nights of being
[ __ ] tortured
all those [ __ ] nights of being
touched at this point i feel like i
[ __ ] up myself i don't know how to
live with that
you know because when [ __ ] gets too much
it's just easier to take a hit than it
is to [ __ ] work through it
that's just where i am now you know
natasha thank you so much for talking
with me thank you i wish you the best of
luck out here
thank you it's horrible for a woman
right it is
thank you
you